charlie theme songs
[Music]
this song is so good
um couch time it's catch time
cool wait we're sitting on the couch
yeah a couch time
oh my god uh yo
uh i'm gonna no are we on the couch or
how do we switch i'll just switch it to
you
42 in my cupboard
uh yo uh what are we gonna oh yeah cause
what's in the box boys
guess what's in the box you know what's
in this box
do they know no it's a 30-90
wait what it was a 30-90 just one 13-90
yeah
we fixed it this is in the box
you know what this is
did i know we got 65 people in here
uh don't worry karma wasn't bought by
facebook i was i was just messing with
you guys
you know what this is wait you told him
that we got by facebook i told him to be
some sick announcements at comic-con
like you know
normally when companies do these cons
you know it's like uh it's gonna
announce some
you know big [ __ ]
um oh yeah yeah yeah yeah the secret new
feature talk all right so
so you know um check it out okay we
clean the cam is it clean now guys
all right they're upset check out the
updated schedule
uh so i sent you guys guys the link
uh don't worry we're not getting
acquired by
facebook um we are
having a conference on july
31st 2021 you can buy tickets here
i believe there's only four more vip
tickets left
uh and we have about 70 general
admission tickets left look this one
includes the fee how come sometimes the
fee is not included and sometimes it's
included
it's 99 for a ticket but then you have
to pay the fees
on please log into your facebook account
to activate emergency braking exactly
um uh will it be the stream
some of the event will be streamed the
daytime talks will be streamed
all of them that's pretty nice to people
i don't know
some people said they would pay to watch
the streams well
no i'm not going to sell digital content
i just don't give you the digital
content you know what i mean
you show up in person or you know you
don't like oh man i used to have some
good some good lines about this about
like you know remote man
like how you're gonna like try to do
things remote like oh yeah no i'm
building a house
no i'm working from home you already
have a home while you're building the
house oh yeah yeah no i'm working from
home
you know it's like that like show up
comic-con it's a real
thing it's here in san diego it's at
1337 india street
uh 137 india we did petition the city to
change the address
yeah not a joke boys um is there an age
limit to attending
uh you have to be accompanied by a
parent or guardian if you're under 18
no anyone can come no like if someone
like 15 year old shows up at the door
that's fine wow that's more nice than i
was thinking
san diego george when did you when did
you go to your first conference when you
were a kid
yeah i was 15. yeah what the
hell hackers on planet earth um all
right
so our first talk uh
what was going to talk about open pilot
see what you guys don't realize about
open pilot
is is drives cars and it's great but
it's also really like
do you know how none of robotics
actually works like there's allegedly
like robotics ecosystems out there but
the best
they've managed to build is like like a
vacuum cleaner that like eats your ipad
cord half the time
like that's just like really and the
reason it's also bad is because no one
built good infrastructure for us
um i made the same argument for ml as
well so um
first talk here from will about how open
pilot uh
you know became good uh then harold's
going to talk
howard was our head of research he's now
our cto
at 11 a.m about how our training stack
works you know carpathi talked about
tesla's training stack
yesterday what tesla's doing now
is what we were doing two or three years
ago right like
you guys think we're gonna win
self-driving cars um
[Music]
nobody can touch things like this model
uh and you're gonna learn right here how
they're made
because you know what we'll tell you
we'll tell you you can copy us if you
think you can i mean you can try but you
know we'll just tell you
uh because you know what we're happy to
we're happy to tell you
um then we have a free lunch at 12.
it's burgers hope y'all like burgers
uh yeah we got we got burgers
um bro
you're gonna miss out if you don't go to
comic-con um
so then uh it's my talk
um i'm not you can read the schedule if
you want to learn more about my talk i'm
not going to be my own height man you
know what i mean
uh you know like the guy's like rapping
i'm doing the beat and then you can't do
both so you guys guys just read it but
uh
uh oh you you won't want to miss this
was supposed to be italics
you did the italics in the event right
yeah there is html
i will update that yeah just put the i
tag around it you know the ipad
hi carly uh
hey then um
yeah there there's there's a big
announcement at comic-con
there's a big announcement uh and if
you're there you'll get to see the big
announcement and if you're not there
you get to hear about the big
announcement later i've been like wow i
could have been
here for the big announcement and not
there
you know um and then we got robe and the
hardware team
are coming up on stage you know kyle
vogt said that it was impossible
powell vote talked about comma and that
was the company that he wanted to build
but
he said it was impossible he said he'll
never be able to support all the cars
and you'll never be able to deal with
you know all the cars having
different versions of firmware and you
know you'll never be able to like attach
nicely to the cars
yeah well yo we did it and we'll tell
you how we did it you guys like you know
it's stuff that if you've been following
closely you know but if you haven't been
following closely you'll be like
wow turns out all the cars are the same
architecture and like all that kind of
that kind of [ __ ] you know it's like we
used to have giraffes man and now we
have harnesses
the harness is nice all right you can
hear about that process of evolution and
you know where we're coming we're going
the pitfalls the possibilities and the
promise
uh coming back to the future all right
um then we got uh then we're going into
the 30 minute talks
uh we got a deeb uh you guys know deep
uh he's gonna reveal a secret new open
pilot feature
never before seen um it's a good feature
something that people have been uh you
know asking about for a long time
and you guys are gonna see it be
revealed at comic-con
for the first time uh at three o'clock
p.m um and greg our head of
infrastructure
uh is going to talk about our amazing
on-prem data center
uh we've built a data center for like a
tenth of the cost of every oh sorry
sorry not a data center we've built a
not a data center
for like a tenth of the cost of
everybody else you guys want to see my
30 90 again
um yo so yeah there's that and uh you
know it's gonna be great we're gonna
have like you know like
you guys want to see like sexy looking
pictures like lots of wires in a bundle
we'll have some of those yo we got we
got wires and bundles like it's really
you guys like the data center looks so
nice you guys haven't seen it
you know we have we have two
pay-to-bites spinning discs we got like
another like
600 terabyte ssd array uh we have then
another like 400 tower we have like
three petabytes in this
you know beautiful rack um 80 gpus
you guys will hear about that um
that way xing is going to talk about you
know our camera based driver monitoring
that's so good that tesla copied it two
years later
uh wishing is a engineer on the research
team he built this in like
half his time so you know i was like oh
it's built by like you know like like
half an engineer
bro that's the power of comma and that's
the power of common infrastructure and
crowd sourcing and big data
and you know not being stupid uh you
know come come learn
how to build uh driver monitoring in a
not stupid away
uh yo everybody like who's making like
crappy tesla you know just watch this
talk i'll be like oh we can make driver
monitoring like that you know we could
have put our leds on all the model
threes but we didn't
um so yeah you know don't do that um
then we're gonna have a group chat we're
going to bring a bunch of team members
up on stage
colin's been a company from six years
now uh you can hear about how we came
from like
you know building hobbyist crap to
building oh well you know
the future the actual like like like you
know uh
i was thinking of the icarly song
so then we got we got a happy hour
uh and we're gonna get people on stage
for community lightning talks
uh i think drewer he said yesterday he
wants to give a 15-minute talk about the
chrysler court
uh so if anyone else is interested in
giving a community lightning talk
uh this is your chance um
then we have dinner uh if you didn't buy
vip you get flatbreads on the first
floor these are the pizzas guys like
we're not
we just call the flatbreads because well
there's not burgers and pizzas burgers
and flatbreads you know burgers are
fancy food you know i was in iceland
once i paid like 60 bucks for a burger
and a beer no joke man
iceland has the iscs uh
been like months since i saw the video
yeah we're chilling for
comic con guys uh oh yeah yeah but if
you bought a vip ticket you get a
beautiful
sit down dinner with us on the third
floor if
this is your chance to pitch us whatever
business development [ __ ] you want to
pitch us and like
you know i think you'll leave this
dinner being like wow i now understand
the world better
um so you know no promises about that
you don't get a refund if you don't feel
like your world changed but
to sit down dinner with the whole team
uh you guys can learn you know what the
new business looks like half of the
phone calls you know i just school
people in the new business
you know you learn like mba [ __ ] you
don't learn how you know like to do
anything
i'm just like oh like they understand at
the end of the phone call why like
their thing isn't real uh you know
i want real things that i want to know
once they say something i want to know
that it really happens
oh uh and then
we have maybe the crowning event uh
congregating uh you know i think like a
bunch of guys on a stage with some beers
and a jeopardy board
i will ask questions and you know we'll
all clap for you if you get the right
answer well
we'll boo if you get the wrong answer uh
two rounds of jeopardy it's going to be
like great common questions
like this release
was the release that included the new ui
do you know you know what were rather
what were
other jeopardy questions that you guys
might want to study
you're going to give away our questions
what does calvi stand for
what's the code name of the panda inside
the comma two
bonus points if you can tell us why
um someday you'll see i know the world's
gonna change your name
and be so wonderful
uh um can i sign your comma two if you
buy a vip ticket
sure why not uh so yeah get in
uh buy your comic-con tickets today
uh before they do sell out uh we're
about halfway through the sale of
comic-con tickets
uh we're a little more than halfway
through the sale of vip tickets
uh so if you guys wanna wanna come to
comic-con uh today would be a good day
to buy your ticket
tomorrow might be an okay to buy your
ticket but the day after that
uh you know you're gonna get there and
it's gonna be like
sold out and oh man you know
just like 39 now 3090s were always sold
out but just like everything else man
you know how many rav4 primes i should
have bought
seven you know what i could sell them
for now double that's right
uh i can't buy vip i'm bringing my wife
with me and that would be 2k hey vip is
not for everybody we appreciate having
you at the conference
you get most of the same experience
except you don't get a vip
look vip is most you guys heard of proof
of burn and crypto
it's proof of burn bro it's proof um
can i ride the hoverboard you think
okay you think more users would increase
the speed of development
why do you think that you think would
develop faster if we had more stupid
issues to answer from people
don't think so bro don't think so
all right what do we got always the
after party you know if you're cool
you'll get invited
uh you know you'll get tapped you've
gotta follow the weight rather than
um all right what are we hearing from
from youtube
they just want to hear the full icarly
theme song don't they
yep the entire schedule is up on our
eventbrite
chris posted a link to it
it's it's a little quiet it's mostly
been garbage
wow just trolling can we get some comma
tequila yeah maybe
three trace commas uh no there will be
some big announcements at comic-con you
think
i would pay you know you know how much
this event costs man
it costs more than the average american
wedding
uh this is this beautiful venue
uh they're like rock stars at this venue
you know but really like uh you know
comic-con
like it's surreal like it's not like
gonna be like some
some some folding chairs in the
auditorium bros we wouldn't we wouldn't
do you like that you know
it's going to be like plush leather
chairs and
vi you know it's like it's like the club
but
not shitty you know like what sucks
about the club
the alcohol is all overpriced and the
music's all really loud and is
dirty this is gonna have
informative talks reasonably priced
alcohol
and nice clean seats you know and
it's not gonna be too loud it's not
gonna be too loud i wouldn't do you guys
like that
you know i'm not here we don't make the
money on drinks bros
what are you looking forward to about
can fd oh
can if all they they heard a little
announcement about can't have d on a
i did ask them if they liked ken fd and
if they like the color red they should
come to comic-con
i did mention that on reddit um
someone asked about esperanto's ai chip
oh i talked to some guy from esperanto
uh you know they just got to get out of
underneath the boot of the professional
managerial class
and then maybe they could build a good
ai chip but as long as they're under
that boot they're going to build
[ __ ] that nobody wants
since you said we don't need more users
what do you need
more quality developers
yeah what do you mean by more time the
software just gets better it just takes
time
it's like a fine line or like you know
you have to age your marijuana it's like
that
uh no i mean we could always use more
quality we could always use more great
developers
right uh you know better developers
geniuses
who want to like you know just like look
at open pilot and be like i can do this
better
that's not we don't need more we need
better
right like i don't want like you know i
have a localizer right like i don't need
two localizers i want a better localizer
all right we don't need more i don't
want to add you know
do hickeys and features i want to take
all the core stuff and just iterate on
until it's better and better and better
and better if that's how you manage
complexity and make things better
it's easy to build features it's hard to
build things that are truly great
reliable robust
you know low cpu consumption
uh yeah like all that kind of stuff
logan asks
what did you think about carpathia's
examples of tesla's radar problems with
phantom breaking in his last talk
what carpathi is talk with a hand
labeled 230 different scenarios bro we
just use contrastive models find them
automatically you know
um we do things automatically if you
can't count the number of things you're
going to do
on one hand and maybe you can get a
two-handed exception but if it's more
than two hands it's definitely way too
many things
uh i know i mean when tesla shows off
the ground trooping stack
this is an example where we are two
years ahead of tesla
you guys know we're two years ahead of
tesla and driver monitoring
uh you know tesla is two years ahead of
us in hardware
um they're six years ahead of us in
fleet size probably
uh i wouldn't actually do that how big
is a tesla fleet size now
it's over a million no it might be about
if you can see if you extrapolate out
comma's current
growth rate i think will be where tesla
is at fleet size
now in like four years
um
so yeah they're quite ahead in that but
again is that really a metric towards
solving self-driving cars the hardware
is nice
uh their hardware is a lot nicer than
ours obviously uh but you know
comic-con just like to say it's
interesting that we announced comic-con
and one week later
elon announced an undated event in a
brand new
common ai car
um we're stealing cruise origins no
actually though we do want of chrysler
pacifica
like i wasn't kidding about that we
actually like want one someone reached
out
they have one and they want to sell it
to us a reasonable price or for a new
scam price
i don't know they didn't name a price
but
to know that your car is going to r d
for a better future that's right your
car has a good future ahead of us it's a
good cost
sell your car to a good cause we'll pay
you money but not scam yes our common
car is gonna be just like zuke's it's
gonna go in both directions
whoa our car already goes in both
directions have you heard of reverse
i mean you look kind of stupid going
reverse on the highway but yeah you
could
it's gonna have v to v um
what about mobile what about them
does comma support the audi a3 some of
them tickets i'm not offering digital
tickets
what is it did you just [ __ ] so lame
guys
we all do zoom calls you know it's real
it's a real event show up
yeah when was the last time anyone went
to a conference
what do you think about honda going
vision only
why are you guys posting junk and
discord or maybe because they can see it
on the video
yo yeah oops wrong chat what is this
junk get your junk out of discord
or we're gonna see some bands coming in
what car would you recommend for a comma
two
georgia's favorite car is the sonata
that's right hyundai sonata
2021 it's a great car it's really
quiet it's a great entertainment system
uh willem's coming out to work on it oh
yeah no all of europe's gonna be here
hello i'm robert ghost are all gonna be
here
oh for comic-con
it's gonna be a great day the whole team
i really don't think you're gonna want
to miss us
that's right i'd get in early bros
um
the accords are nice these are pretty
nice
you want to talk about our new employees
no
oh can you ask george about vision honda
getting vision only
like you know i don't like when people
aren't about me so i wouldn't do that to
their employees you know
um honda's getting vision only
i mean like we used to just video and
new employees
just walk around you know and startle
them
yeah i don't know i think we're too big
for that now it's too much of a
corporate environment now
so corporate here yes yost is on fire
with the new comma explorer
right we also love everything he's doing
do you want to show them a new explorer
i don't have to wear masks at the event
can you work a common eye without a
degree yes but not without skills
um do you want to show them some new
stuff in explorer
i can't go to my explorer oh it's got
too many secrets
um is blockchain and auto
an open pilot are are not intertwining
anytime soon to be done to filter out
common bad habits question from the beal
no um what kind of books do i have
behind me
lots of books you want to learn about
convex optimization
yeah probabilistic robotics
machine learning
oh yeah we got a google pixel
yeah you know and the bible
mcmaster car oh yeah
uh i hope there's no secrets on your
whiteboard
sorry guys i'm gonna see if i can tripod
us
except for a new evaluation oh hell yeah
yeah that's what common shares are going
for on the open market now
474 million
but it's all fake money you know what i
mean you're gonna be like like
like have you guys heard of the weimar
republic
oh my god you're good i helped fix it
thank you what's this thing
try putting falling apart and whenever
you're good you tighten the back
okay good
is that good yeah it's just on georgia's
screen now yo
you guys remember young's
you know what eons are not for sale
but common twos are for sale you guys
can buy one today
or a comic-con ticket um
what else we got sure i think
i think that's kind of it we're really
excited about the schedule
i think that
i didn't need to carry it on my phone oh
yeah some car companies reached out
oh yeah car companies are always
reaching out
car companies are always reaching out
but they're not ready to embrace the
future yet
they'll know when they're ready does
anyone have any other
other um compatible cars they'd like to
sell us for a good price
we're in the market would you like to um
donate your car to comma
donate your car it's a write-off
it's not this car charity write-offs
a lot of the 100 cars for kids
i hear they didn't actually go to kids
they went to like pawn shops
um what kind of car do you have creator
259
we're interested if it's flex right you
got to pay us to take it
250 cap we'll do flex rate for 250k
or do you know what some guy was like
will you pour it to like my porsche 911
and what i said about that was if you
buy me a porsche 911 we'll pour it
that is cheaper than the 250k it is
cheaper
um i think that they're going to let the
canadians across the border before july
31st
i think if you're a canadian you'll be
able to make it and um i can
write you a letter saying that this is
important business can we
i don't know if we want to extend our
credibility like that
well for a vip for vip i mean you know
they're very important
obviously this is a business meeting a
fair point it is a business meeting it
is an important business meeting
i would happily write as write a note
from comma recommending that the us
government consider letting you cross
that's right if you're a vip we do that
is george still buying iphones
i mean he does have the latest iphone no
i don't
you were the latest iphone i heard the
battery life was better on the 11. so i
stopped for a while
the battery life's better now no i don't
like it it's too square
it's it's beautiful i love the latest
iphone
i'll help your mechanics if you help me
with my signals for fiber optics and
mnemonics
that's it that's it uh wait how many
tickets we sell them is they found the
stream
i look on my phone but it's streaming oh
that's a fair point
yo hopefully we sold a lot of tickets we
want this event to have a lot of people
um guys we got to sell tickets you know
the events of fixed price
you guys got to come to the event
because we got to you know like we want
there to be a comic con next year
we got to come to this comic con man
yeah ernie jimenez with the 2020
pacifica hybrid
did we want a 2018 uh
are we open to a 2020. um we got to talk
to a dude this is the deepest division
is it going to be better than ces uh
without a doubt
oh yes yes cs was okay
[Music]
well george rabbit you guys common
jeopardy
is is there's so many unknowns you just
don't know what can happen
with a lot of hype and energy it's not
going to be recorded
there's going to be a lot of drinking
and active and fun and like who knows
what will happen
um i love t-pain but he will not be
there i'll send him an invite
oh yo i went to this
concert ones and they got the gangnam
twins
i hear we were able to get them what
lange
um we might have some special guests
special guest i have reached out to some
friends of comma
yeah um
no promises but
yeah cool you want it you want to hit
header real quick one more time in the
schedule
all right you call it oh we're gonna do
again just like i'm not an
actor man you know actors never watch
them they do the same line in the same
way all right we'll do the schedule
we'll do a little different
look i don't think elon's gonna come but
we'll send him a link to the live stream
because i think there's a lot for him to
learn
we didn't buy carpathian her family can
come
um we haven't said the email yet i was
waiting for the schedule to launch oh
would you like
me to microphone yeah there's an open
email on my computer we invited
uh no compatibility is actually really
cool uh we'd love to have him at the
conference
uh we're also inviting anthony levdowski
um
you know lebanowski's legitimate genius
man he doesn't get enough credit for
this stuff you know
he really doesn't get that like ramo got
taken over by lame people you know what
i said i would do if i was in charge of
waymo i put leadowski in charge
only he can think big enough to save
lima he's a
gigantic man with gigantic ideas he's
six foot six
i've heard that um
okay one more i'm gonna do a run through
the schedule
all right
i'm gonna open with chris and then
william the head of openpilot is going
to talk
uh then harold our cto is going to talk
about
models then we have burgers for lunch
george oh my god
we got spin drift everywhere i can't
leave that on the
oh george
this is just uh
and then greg's our head of
infrastructure is gonna speak
um
we got spin drift everywhere on the
couch
my pants are wet now
[Laughter]
um the happy hour with community
lighting talks
shoot me an email alexa comma dot ai
comic con is going to go better than the
live stream i hear you spilled stuff
yeah yeah we spilled stuff everywhere
what'd you do oh wait you're watching
you wanna watch just clean up the
spindrift
here we go wow that's a lot yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa alex left in the
precarious place
i stopped watching the stream for like
three seconds i look back whoa there's
spin drift everywhere
[Laughter]
um it cleans up pretty well where are we
on
look like i'll give you a lot of high
level overviews
you know reverse engineer is all about
moving up layers of abstraction um the
morning talks
are the in-depth uh technical talks
um where you'll get you know serious
information
about uh how open pilot works how a
training stack works
um then there's lunch
uh i talk after lunch
i mean if there are big announcements
you know
uh maybe that's when they'd be uh
and then we got the hardware team
uh talking you know we got like okay so
it's like the morning
solid software the hardware chunk
and then we got like the different
pieces you know we got we got like
the secret new feature we got driver
monitoring and we got infrastructure
um i don't have a nice group chat it's
gonna be like uh you know like a
look at how far we've come you know like
everyone's in the rainbow connection
it's like that
uh you know and then yeah
common jeopardy uh we came up with the
prize at lunch
you guys legit aren't gonna believe what
a fifteen thousand dollar value you guys
are not gonna believe what the prize is
it's gonna be great great prize so yeah
that's what we got
that's the stream and i'll leave you
guys with uh the icarly freestyle
what it can't be copyrighted if you
point the camera at the screen
too raw boy
bye everyone i'll see you all comic-con
comic-con
all right let's go